foreign
good afternoon everyone
my name is Dr Miller and the SCP we're
going to be looking at today
is SCP 3140.
containment class safe
disruption class dark and risk class
caution
special containment procedures
scp-3141 is stored in an enlarged
containment hanger at armed containment
area 40 in an inactive state with access
to an underground testing area any
testing must be approved by level 4 3140
Personnel during testing the 3140s
subject must be watched by researchers
and security outside of the testing area
upon conclusion of the testing the
anomaly must be deactivated and brought
to its chamber
investigations into the uses of scp-3140
in davik society and whether other
instances of the anomaly exist are
ongoing
revision one
level 4 3140 approval is required for
the planting of seeds recovered from
scp-3140 instances the guidelines in
document 3140 hrt1 must be followed for
the initial planting
revision 2.
scp-3142 and
scp-3143 will be stored in enlarged
containment hangers at Botanical Garden
beta level 4 3140 approval is required
for testing with either or both of
anomalies
description
scp-3141 is the only extant member of
scp-3140 a group of arboreal entities
scp-3141's body primarily consists of
compresses gigantea and prunus saralana
bark and wood standing in a height of 12
meters the Torso of its body is roughly
spherical with multiple flowering cherry
branches and small cherry trees growing
from it the anterior side has a stylized
eye etched into it which is surrounded
by illustrations of davic Weaponry
cultural symbols and skulls with seven
eye sockets
the posterior portion has a circular
thalmic glyph pattern or TDP with a
radius of 26 centimeters which prevents
fire and erosion damage three anterior
facing wooden barrels one meter long and
28 centimeters wide with a single hole
on the front or on the Torso one is
attached above the right leg one extends
from a dorsal branch on the right side
and one is positioned one meter left of
the eye symbol
two wooden digitigrade legs are
connected to the sides of the anomaly
these legs possess full articulation due
to the wood at the joints being
intermixed with an unknown green and
pink substance designated 3140c the legs
are ornately carved with iconography of
David's soldiers killing and eating
people Soldiers with unidentified Mega
fauna and entities resembling scp-3140
besieging castles and cities and slaves
being given to the Deva matriarchs the
bottom left of the leg features a
hand-shaped recess with a depth of 11
centimeters with the phrase for the
Conqueror written in davic found in the
center the Fate have three long toes two
anterior and one posterior
in an inactive State
scp-3141 sits in a crouching position
any subject Hereafter designated 3140s
that places their left hand in the
hand-shaped recess and says the davic
word for awaken will activate
scp-3141 making it stand upright the
anomaly will begin to follow 3140s and
will follow directions said in davik
directions that scp-3141 is incapable of
achieving will not be followed saying
the devic word for sleep will bring the
anomaly back to its inactive State and a
3140s May reactivate
scp-3141 at any time by saying awaken
within the anomalies vicinity in any
language
the following are a sample of known
directions
scp-3141 will follow all spoken in davik
and the outcomes
move
scp-3140 moves to a location
3140s points to
Stomp
scp-3141 moves two and Stomps at a
location 3140s points to
stab various bone spikes roughly 25
centimeters long emerged from every
surface of the anomaly these retract
after one minute
slide
a mix of translucent low viscosity
substances cover
scp-3141 falling off of it after three
minutes
bring help
scp-3141 secretes a substance similar to
alarm pheromones of an extant insect
species for two minutes
heal
resin seeps from random locations on the
anomaly primarily around the barrels
fire
smoke emerges from the barrels on
scp-3141
see document 3140 seamless for further
commands
scp-3141 was discovered at a foundation
archaeological dig site near bakuno
Jammu and Kashmir Republic of India on
27th of January 2017. the dig site
appeared to have at one point been the
location of a battle between David
forces and an unknown artoefin group
based on the presence of non-anomalous
weapons and armor possessing acute
heptagrams sometimes surrounded by other
polygons regular polygons ranging from
four to seven sides and humanoid figures
with four to seven arms
said battle is believed to have occurred
at some point in the early low davic
period Circa 11 000 BCE suspected to be
the century Conquest
around
scp-3141's legs were chained leg cuffs
made of meteoric iron locked with a
complex mechanical system with the
phrase ruination to the Invaders written
in ortothan on both cuffs the chains had
been heavily damaged likely from
attempts to break them the remnants of
an scp-3140 instance were found at dig
sites in the vicinity which had damaged
legs and a destroyed torso The torso's
Remains had a solidified mass of
miscellaneous plant matter and Bone
fragments in it connected by multiple
small Roots other objects in the area
included bones weaponry and armor all
artifacts the destroyed instance and
scp-3141 were transported to area Forney
on 29th of January 2017.
based on texts found in
scp-1726 and scp-140
scp-3140 were a common weapon utilized
by the davic Empire during and after the
century Conquest though it is suggested
that the anomaly had predated daveite
civilization pharmaturgic Horticulture
methods would be used to grow different
variations of the entities primarily
designed for military application
below are several text excerpts
detailing the growth and usage of
scp-3140 in davite society translated
next to the prisoner slaughtering
grounds I saw a massive Farm it
stretched out from the clearing which I
estimated to be 60 herbs long 50 years
wide and passed the corpses possibly
farther
I estimate the clearing to be 61 herbs
many growing and grown moons are in the
plots possibly 100 or more the area has
less guards though many experienced
presence etherbenders occupied a hill in
an unguarded region gave the perfect
view and the holy raised tube praised
the elemental holies and proved it
death to the brutes etherbenders walked
the columns and would stop by the mature
and crouched ones then retrieve objects
from their red robes ether black would
flash in their hands as they retrieved
the materials and inserted them into the
moon which rippled like water during the
process
I could not easily Glimpse the materials
for they were clouded by The Ether black
Air but the holy raised tube praised the
elemental holies illuminated Spirit
residual outlines of bone and flesh
after the process ended a quick change
would occur to the Golem tentacles like
the deepers I suggest an investigation
to see if a deeper pact was formed
Cannons of great size and with many
barrels and spikes to rival our Spears
all grew instantaneously
The Ether Benders would move on to the
next and the soldier would lead slaves
likely captured Warriors by Chain to the
wooden Beast they were all starved and
scarred and trembled with every step if
they did not begin to etch davik death
to the brutes victories and violence
onto the Golems a small rod would be
stabbed into their back and they would
immediately return to work
some of these artists had dozens stuck
into them
correspondence from katine diraj to
weisard Anton Circa 11030 BCE of the
early on tipa describing an overview of
a devite provisional Camp documents 1726
the first attackers were David's
soldiers who emerged from the jungle at
the Early Sunrise to assault the Gateway
luckily our warriors were as prepared as
the 10th Y prophesized and promised for
they had a great many traps weapons and
strong fortifications our arches up on
the wall did little to assist them and
the onlook is up here myself included
cheered we knew the David Empire was the
greatest to ever exist so this victory
was truly glorious
I was nervous though the countless
stories of endless victories and The
Taming of the great beasts that belonged
in other Realms came back to me an
attack with so few soldiers seemed wrong
after a Jolin had passed with no new
action the crowd around the Arches grew
smaller but our good Warriors stood
strong with anticipation another Jolin
later most had left to return to their
homes in or around the inner city and
The Archers began to speak about
unrelated events unusually the Chimes of
safety had not rung despite the apparent
victory
that was when I heard a rumble and saw
trees swaying from my window suddenly
three large beings of wood and leaves
Rose above the Horizon their bodies were
like castles of wood and their legs were
larger than any tree trunk I have seen
in my hands each had vast numbers of
Daylights scrambling along stairwells
lined with bark plating on the exterior
and unfortified platforms covered by
large trees strange pink and blue
flowers blossomed all over a few holes I
could see on their fronts suggests they
have an interior as well
the hundred cannons fired in unison from
the top and middle of the war but the
tree beasts kept walking more and more
were fired and only small pieces of the
things would shatter the ground troops
were being attacked from all sides by
smaller wood creatures some still taller
than any man I saw a man have spiked
Vines wrap around his body and rip him
like cloth and another was impaled by
several wooden spikes the traps and
barricades were stepped on and broken
and The Archers and Cannon workers were
killed by David's arrows as they got
closer to the top of the wall I grabbed
all I could and ran from my home and
into the city
a jar later I heard the Chimes of
invasion ring from all around
written by matrani John in his personal
diary circuit
10950 BCE describing the invasion of the
elude city-state by David troops
documents 1726 991
clouds swelled in the sky as my boat
sailed along the coast as with all sunk
Creations it was efficient and simple
but I feared it would collapse at any
moment after an euro I was able to see
the edge of the etan Clans village the
rest was hidden in dense foliage the
mass in codexes claimed the clan to be a
relic of Empire davik a fragment of
David a much debated idea as none could
verify from risk of death or worse this
day I could see well that they were
fragmented David
huts and sculptures of bone were common
occasional villagers and guards walking
around the only crop I saw was a large
and thin tree growing slices of meat on
the branches
guards would grab a slice and eat and
another would grow soon after a likely
solution for the few animals and humans
that could be fed on
small luosa wood deities tamed and used
for war were fishing using tens of arms
on their front once all armed claws had
grabbed a fish they would drop them into
a basket that would then be put into a
hole on another iosia this one would
then trudge into the forest Vanishing
this repeated Without End
Illustrated modern world travels Circa
800 BCE and incomplete book describing
the author's journey to learn about the
cultures and Societies in Central and
East Asia sketches of the described
locations are also present though most
of them are poor in quality and many
passages are largely incoherent the
writer is presently unknown document
1726 24.
full text and artwork related to
scp-3140 instances can be found in
document 3140 historical documents
the use of scp-3140 decreased over time
gradually replaced in favor of
thamaturgic mechanical weapons however
some David Clans continue to use the
entities for hard labor farming and
protection the last remaining ones are
suspected to have been destroyed by
forces under Chinese General Zhang Kai
Circa 270 BCE
addendum one on 1st of March 2017 two
seeds designated 3142 and 3 retrieved
from
scp-3141 were planted in an enlarged
Botanical Garden Botanical Garden beta
in area 40 following David Horticulture
instructions found in documents 1726 801
and 1726 822 compiled in document 3140
HRT
said instructions utilized multiple
anomalous compounds and thematurgic
rituals carried out by thamaturgy
division Personnel
scp-3142 would be grown without
modifications being made while
scp-3143 would be grown for use in
farming by May several wooden spheres
with small branches extending from them
had grown and by July growths resembling
legs had formed
andantum 2. on 5th of September 2017
scp-3142 and 3 had fully grown and had
broken out of their dirt plots following
their relocation to separate containment
Chambers testing regimens began
scp-3142 is largely the same as
scp-3141 though it lacks any
inscriptions
etchings or barrels the anomaly is
unresponsive to the fire command the
leading explanation for the lack of
barrels is that they were added to the
entity after it had fully grown which is
unlikely to carry over to offspring
Research into adding these onto the
anomaly is ongoing
scp-3143 lacks the same features as
scp-3142 and has a largely different
body structure than scp-3140 the entity
has a height of 4 meters and a 3 meter
wide torso the underside possesses a
massive tendrils made of wood and 3140c
Each of which have a different structure
Personnel have successfully used
scp-3143 in the cultivation of soybeans
rice turmeric and sugarcane with various
commands using the tendrils to achieve
this however the process is slower than
existing mechanical farming methods
further research is being performed to
cfscp 3140 instances could be utilized
by the foundation which includes tests
to see if instances could learn new
commands after growth
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to zarguran
they accept
oh crap guy
Trey Adams
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
your local Foundation agent
sagnar
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Dean dingus
braided Peach
Rowan O'Brien
cake neck
gremnir
extra moments one two three
Swift Raw
and James Wright
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you